he also said that he'd be happy if the
Ravens sign Antonio Brown the cousin of
Hollywood Brown who was a first-round
pick of the Ravens last year they were
working out a few weeks ago they had the
non social distancing photograph
afterward with Antonio Hollywood and
Lamar the Ravens are one of the teams
one of the only teams that I think would
do it Chris especially because it would
stick it to the Steelers a little bit
but Brown has those multiple potential
suspensions hanging over his head I
don't know when he's ever gonna be
cleared to come back no I don't either
and I don't think that's gonna be
happening anytime soon
I do agree with you that I think one of
the Baltimore is one of those teams that
you know could make it work with Antonio
Brown there's enough of a culture there
the way John Harbaugh runs the football
team they've had some personalities in
the organization over the years anyways
to where yeah I think it's it's set in
place right now for a place to succeed
for Antonio Brown now I don't know how
Antonio Brown would feel if it's like
week 7 and man they're running the ball
like you know 40 times a game and Lamar
Jackson's run it all over the field he's
only get three or four catches a game
that would probably be my biggest scare
of him on that football team what
happens when Antonio's mad that his
little cousin has better stats than he
does and he's not getting the ball
enough that's to me where I could get a
little interesting well and what happens
if John Harbaugh eventually has to get
rid of Antonio Brown and his little
cousins relationship with the Ravens is
poisoned now they're sharing what a jerk
John Harbaugh is and you need to get to
a different team you need to get out of
Baltimore that's part of the risk that
you're accepting if you embrace Antonio
Brown
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports